هذا المشهد لم نراه لم يكن موجود على
الاطلاق اليوم خلال ساعات الصباح الاولى
هذا المشهد هنا بيوت متنقله مستوطنونا كما
نرى قوات الاحتلال تقوم بحمايتها
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم تقارير اسرائيليه تظهر
تضاعف التوسع الاستيطاني في الضفه الغربيه
وتسجيله ارقاما قياسيه منذ تشكيل حكومه
ايطالياهو وضمن هذا التوسع مستوطنون
ينشؤون بؤره استيطانيه على اراضي قريه ام
صفا وقوه اسرائيليه تقيم بيوتا متنقله على
اراضي اللبن الشرقيه استعدادا لاقامه بؤره
جديده جنوب نابلس قصف جوي ومدفعي كثيف
يستهدف مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم واندرمان ونائب رئيس مجلس السياده
يرفض مبادره الاتحاد الافريقي لحل الازمه
ويصف مبادره الايجاد بمبادره احتلال ويقول
انها تسعى لادخال قوات دوليه الى السودان
وجعل منطقه الخرطوم منزوعه السلاح توتر
جديد بين ايران وفرغانستان بسبب انقطاع
مياه نهرها المند الذي ينبع من افغانستان
المحافظات الايرانيه طهران اتهمت كابول
بقطع تدفق المياه هي عبر بناء السدود
والحكومه الافغانيه ترفض التنازل عن
مسمتها حقوقها المائيه وترحب باي حوار
لبحث
الاتحاد الاوروبي يوقف مدرب روما
الايطاليه جوزيمورينو اربعه مباريات
لتهجمه على احد حكام نهائي الدوري
الاوروبي نهايه الشهر الماضي كما سيعاقب
نادي روما بخمسين الف يورو وسيمنع انصاره
من حضور مباراته المقبله بسبب القيام
باعمال تخريب الى اللقاء